[Música]
han sentido alguna vez la carga del
pasado
con sentido al realizar algún gesto que
algo perteneciente al ayer o alguien del
ayer se metía en eso yo sí muchas veces
el sentido que hago la cara de pilla de
mi abuela que congeló la mirada haciendo
cálculos aritméticos como mi padre o que
se me escapa una risa como mi madre
cuanto de lo que hemos vivido nos
condicionan
de qué manera todo el recorrido que
hemos tenido en la infancia nos conduce
la mirada
yo vengo de dos ríos que dan al mar como
dice fito mis abuelos y mis abuelas eran
tan diferentes como los dos extremos de
una recta los maternos cuyanos llegaron
a la ciudad de venado tuerto escapando
de dos plagas consecutivas de langostas
con sus hijos a cuestas con mi madre los
paternos muy bien afincados en venado mi
abuela me contaba que los invitaban a
los cumpleaños de 15 porque le regalaban
a la cumpleañera un collar de perlas
cultivadas
y que la primera bicicleta que mi padre
tuvo fue una inglesa
pero no por el modelo sino porque mi
abuelo se la había mandado a pedir de
londres
le daban muchos gustos a mi padre a mi
padre le gustaban mucho los pastelitos
entonces le daban plata para que cuando
saliera de la escuela fuera corriendo a
la esquina a comprarse 5 o 6 pastelitos
se comiera 2 regalara el resto a él le
encantaban los pastelitos de don mora
con los años no solo le gustaron los
pastelitos de dos moras sino la hija de
don mora
y se casó con la hija de dos mora y dos
mora se convirtió en mi abuelo materno
aquel que venía escapando de los
langostas
los extremos de una recta que son
serán formas de ver una misma cosa son
tan diferentes
cuando empecé a dedicarme más
profesionalmente a la música apareció
una idea troncal tenéis que hacer buena
música y te deja pensando que si hay
buena tal vez haya mala no y yo digo
bueno que será la buena música pero
pienso la buena música debe ser la que
es difícil de aprender y como cuando uno
escucha que entra alguien y dice yo hago
jazz y da la sensación de que es un
einstein de la música y yo sabía de
memoria dos discos de la fich era dije
guau
la cosa debe ir por ahí y me metí y ahí
apareció mi primer banda adulta que se
llama pantallas hermoso proyecto que no
llegó a editar su disco y buena música
uno piensa buena música y pensase en la
edad media cuando la iglesia condena
ciertas melodías porque decía que el
se metía en ella no que generaba
una sensación medio medio extraña algo
pasaba eso qué tal
de algo que genera mirar
pasa algo pasa algo y con pampa todo lo
que hacíamos era pensado y repensado
craneado analizado y revisado repensado
y tal vez en algún momento lo íbamos a
mostrar
vanessa
qué pasa con lo que te pasa
un día de noviembre de 2012 dos meses
después de que falleciese mi madre en un
centro cultural que teníamos acá en
rosario con unas compañeras
decidimos festejar el aniversario
invitamos a amigos amigas y empezamos a
ensayar una música que fuese alegre
pensamos en cumbia y entre la cumbia en
gilda
cuando un ser querido muere las cosas
cambian de perspectiva descubrí caras
afectos actitudes crear más tu lista de
prioridades porque cuando un ser querido
muere
la vida es valorada y todas esas cosas
en lo cotidiano que acaparan tu atención
y están en un primer plano pasan a un
plano muchísimo muchísimo más secundario
el día que cante es hilda por primera
vez que hice un pacto con la vida me
dije a mí misma dónde están esos
pensamientos que te dicen que hacer esto
está bien que hacer aquello está mal
mira vos estás triste hoy porque tu mamá
murió pero sabes que mira mira esa gente
que estuvo con vos mira los amigos como
te abrazaron agradece el es cantar es
algo que tenga que ver con ese
sentimiento
y bueno así fue me puse una mini que
hacía 18 años que no me ponía
medias rojas tacos pelucas y fui yo la
que en medio de ese vuelo decidí gritar
a viva voz canciones que no se
encontrarán en la danza sin pensar si lo
hacía bien si lo hacía mal y mucho menos
pensar que esa misma noche iba a caer la
primera contratación así nació sirve los
del alba
[Música]
bueno y así fue que sin planearlo me
viene un escenario cantando cumbia y
mientras yo cantaba la gente bailaba
saltaba se abrazaba reía y a mí se me
abrazaban las neuronas pero no con z con
s se me prendía fuego el cerebro ya que
qué estamos haciendo qué pasa la gente
baila está acá festejando el encuentro
está festejando la vida la vida que
tantas veces carece de lógica y ahí
nomás en un principio el juicio tardó
muy poco en aparecer que hacer vanessa
qué estás haciendo
pero no ves que la gente se va de con
esto no aportas nada sos una más como
esos esos programas de tele barato a una
mera entretenedor a la gente se evade se
vuelve menos crítica
hay peor juicio que nuestra propia
mirada
por suerte los conciertos siguieron y
las contrataciones y el trabajo y algo
se iba fisurando se iba moviendo y yo
era parte de lo que se movía
emoción la palabra emoción viene del
latín en mover que significa movimiento
moverse
qué bueno
cada uno de nosotros de nosotras somos
presas de nuestras ideas y cosmovisión
pero tan presa sos pero tan preso sos
que no podés ver ni la reja de la cárcel
porque las paredes de tu prisión son tu
molde
pero hay algo hay algo por allá hay algo
que empieza a aparecer hay algo
tímidamente aparece lentamente aparece y
te dice te voy a trepar
te voy a abrazar
te voy a poner los pelos de punta como
una brisa fría por la espalda como el
sabor poderoso de un bocado y vos no me
vas a poder controlar como no controlan
la vida y como no pudiste controlar la
muerte
qué bueno así pasó así siguió yo no sé
realmente bien por qué dejé que pasara
había un sabor aroma nuevo a fresco la
cumbia era eso era era algo espontáneo
era algo primitivo pero no por básico
por primero tenía sabor a cadera a la
cadera por donde para una mujer por
donde gozamos nuestra sexualidad a la
cadera de dónde saca la fuerza un
futbolista para patear el penal a esa
cadera a la cadera del movimiento no la
cadera que carga pesos la cadera que sea
se traba en una silla no la de la
excitación rítmica la de llevar y de
dejarse llevar
en tiempos en donde nos encontramos a
través de
pantallas en donde nos hablamos a través
de
pantallas en donde nos vemos a través de
pantallas
estar ahí en vivo y en directo
moviéndote con otros dejándote llevar
que te puede hacer evadir eso si estás
ahí
estás en contacto tenés piel tenés
mirada
estás
el movimiento genera movimiento una
pensó una persona que se mueve no no no
quiere objetos porque los objetos se
traban te molestan te dificultan son una
carga para moverte solo tienes que estar
ahí
y nada más tal vez la emoción puede
hacer una fisura una grieta en ese muro
yo
vengo de dos ríos que dan al mar pero
también soy todos los nuevos ríos que
quieran cruzar me
no importa si el abuelo mora hacía
pastelitos o el abuelo bachelier y
regalaba a collar de perlas cultivadas y
si vanessa creía que el movimiento
estaba en el jazz y hoy se mueve
bailando cumbia mientras canta lo
importante es que detrás de esos
pastelitos de esos collares de esas
canciones haya emoción movimiento vida
yo creo que puede haber una emoción ahí
rascando el muro rasguñando el muro
tratando de figurar los déjala entrar
puede haber un mundo impensado del otro
lado y vos te lo mereces no te quedes
afuera por quedarte adentro
no debemos de pensar
que todo es diferente
mil momentos como éste
que van en mi mente no se piensa en el
verano
cuando el área
que pasen momentos
volveremos a querernos
no podrá faltar cuando falte todo
alrededor
el aire que respiro en aquel país
vivo con la fuerza que necesita para no
matar
[Música]
todo
aire que respiro en la casa que no viva
[Música]
necesita
dónde
[Música]
m
tú me das
amor
o
ah
[Música]
gracias funcional fidelidad para bruce
favorable
la lista de sigla me lo permita
me arrepiento de este amor aunque me
cuente el corazón a mano es un milagro
yo te amé como nunca jamás me imaginé
como para arrancarme de tu piel de tu
recuerdo de taller siento que la vida se
nos más que un día de hoy no vuelve más
después de cerrar la puerta nuestra cama
de la la locura apasionada del
amor mientras te quiero y te quiero
vamos demostrando el cielo si no puedo
arrepentirme de este amor
aunque me recuerdo de tener siento que
la vida se nos va
[Música]
sí